you'll never guess what this is we're
making leftover crawfish boil pasta I
know stay with me here I had some
leftovers for my family's crawfish boils
so I figured why not give the leftovers
another life I strained some crawfish
broth from the boil into a pot with some
sauteed onions and then leftover sausage
and potatoes after letting it reduce for
a bit I threw in some cream and cheese
to balance the intensity of the flavors
and once that thickens up I added in the
rest of the Corn and the Crawfish tail
this goes in some pasta water and then
the nudes stir and then serve with some
parsley pepper and lots and lots of
lemon